Ugandan troops have served in the
African Union peacekeeping Mission in
Somalia for 15 years
last week al-shabab Fighters attacked
their base in Bula Maria in the lower
shabella region the Ugandan government
took days to confirm the number of
deaths al-shaba claimed they killed over
Ugandan peacekeepers in that incident in
the Ugandan military did it with
casualties they did suffer casualties
but did not reveal the number as of
until today in which they claimed 54
were killed the Somali government has
been making gains against the armed
group for months it's taken back sways
of territory and encouraged somalis to
work with the government to reveal
al-shabab hideouts but it appears the
armed group is still capable of
launching a large-scale attack against
an African Union base despite gaining
territory
is still able to strike targets at will
whether it be Somali government
installations or foreign military bases
as you've seen with the latest incident
targeting the Uganda military base
Ugandan president URI museveni says his
soldiers did not perform as expected and
panicked
number 70 had threatened to reduce the
number of troops serving in the African
Union Mission after funding Cuts in
2020.
there's also pressure at home to end the
mission in Somalia
and now after last week's raid two
senior officers are facing a
court-martial to answer for one of the
largest number of Ugandan deaths in a
single attack in Somalia
Barbara angopa Al Jazeera